you might have been saying everything is
bigger in Texas right even the
sandwiches are so Texas melts executive
chef Larry sketta is here to help us
celebrate National sandwich month Las
Vegas biggest and boldest grilled
sandwich yes what does that mean how did
you guys get that title
well we uh we make our sandwich big and
stuff with a lot of meat and uh
that's why we have a name of Texas
smells home of the Texas size grilled
sandwiches take the side real sandwiches
I love it okay so let's talk about how
you guys are celebrating for National
sandwich month I hear there's a weekly
buy one get one deal is that right okay
it's about menu well Texas miles will
feature its favorite sandwich each week
buy one get one free okay okay uh the
first week we have the Dallas which is
the brisket
and the second week is the um uh Midland
which is got a little bit of different
cheese on there right it's like a Philly
cheese steak we're on a Texas toast okay
and then we have the pulled Porky which
is the Houston okay and we have the
Corpus Christi it's a half a pound
burger
with smoked brisket on it
smoked 16 to 22 hours
oh my gosh yes okay
and last but certainly
got cooking sizzling we are going to
prepare the Texas a Big Tex
the big text okay so I let you
um put the cheese on okay on the you got
okay yeah yes this is grilled onions
okay so while I put the cheese on we've
got about a minute to build this
sandwich well I put the cheese on
explain the text how that's special
because if you've never had Texas toast
well the Texas toast is basically just a
a Pullman sandwich cut thicker okay okay
so and then Brown it just a little yes
we're going to melt the cheese a little
bit there you go
we have to melt the cheese a little bit
the Texas way that's why it melts
all right all right there you go now if
you don't have one of those at home
perhaps you could use I don't know a
stove microwave microwave okay and then
this is our smoked brisket oh my God
okay we got a little a little time left
here all right throw it on there then we
have we have the pulled pork okay we're
gonna put that on top go and while you
finish this off go ahead keep it keep
moving um but while you finish it so you
have to be a Rewards member to actually
get the buy one get one right yes all
they have to do is sign up okay not easy
as that yeah and this is uh we put a
little bit of barbecue sauce on it oh my
God all right and then and the cheese
on top okay I'm gonna melt it a little
bit oh and then we put the bacon on and
then we put the bacon we're gonna talk
to Tasty so let's let's get the finished
product
okay
and then they put the bacon all right
they go
and then we put the last the last there
you go I'm not gonna bite this on air
because that's going to be a mess but if
you see that
JC I'll send it over to you
all right I'll send it back oh